les accusations ont d'abord été lancé
par les autorités russes selon
lesquelles des armes biologiques
auraient été découvertes sur le sol
ukrainien dans de prétendus laboratoire
secret financée par washington
des allégations qui ont provoqué une
cascade de réactions à londres le
premier ministre dénonce des mensonges
répandus par un gouvernement cynique et
barbe à ces accusations ont éveillé les
soupçons des chancelleries occidentales
qui craignent de voir la russie recourir
à des armes chimiques dans la guerre en
ukraine les russes commence par dire
qu'il y a des armes chimiques qui ont
été stockés par leurs opposants ou par
les américains et donc quand eux-mêmes
déploie des armes chimiques comme je
crains qu'ils le fassent ils ont une
fausse histoire toute prête il
existerait ainsi selon le kremlin preuve
à l'appui une trentaine de laboratoires
secrets en ukraine où des recherches sur
des agents pathogènes serait mené les
états unis démentent et parle
d'installations de recherche biologique
en ukraine pour auch in town ces
allégations sont une tactique régulière
de la russie elle avait déjà en 2018
accusé les américains de mener des
expérimentations biologique dans un
laboratoire de géorgie
diffuser leurs des informations mais il
faut que le monde comprenne qu ils ont
non seulement la capacité mais également
des antécédents d'utilisation d'armes
chimiques et biologiques et qu'en ce
moment nous devrions être attentifs à
cette possibilité des craintes partagées
par le camp ukrainien
cela m'inquiète vraiment car si vous
voulez comprendre les plans de là aussi
il suffit de voir de quoi elle accuse
les autres le fait de répandre de telles
accusations dans les médias russes
révèle que ce sont eux qui en sont
capables
l'armée et les services secrets russes
la russie a été à plusieurs reprises
accusé de recourir à des armes chimiques
ou biologiques comme dans la guerre en
syrie ou dans des affaires
d'empoisonnement nos vies de choc ce
qu'elle a toujours démenti
béni